So today we're going to
continue, uh, to, uh,
talk about applications of
a biomedical engineering.
So it sort of a way to bring together
some of the concepts that we've talked
about over the last,
uh, over the last, uh,
several months and a Tuesday I
focused on applications in cancer.
And so we thought about how
imaging techniques, how, uh,
instruments that deliver
radiation, how, uh,
molecules and cells could be used to treat
cancer. And today we're going to, the,
the focus is going to be on,
on artificial materials.
So biomaterials, uh, which are
widely used in medicine now, uh,
and were produced largely through the
work of material scientists and chemical
engineers in biomedical engineers
over the last a hundred years or so.
So we'll talk about
some of the, of the, uh,
difficulties with creating a material
that can be implanted in the body.
And we'll talk about some
of the applications of,
uh, of those materials. Uh,
particularly in artificial organs is
where I want to end up for the day.
So, uh, these are two pictures
from the text, uh, that I, uh,
that I present this to show
you that the idea of using, uh,
artificial materials to replace tissues
that are lost for one reason or another
is not new.
And so I'm,
the one picture here shows a
remarkable discovery from a mummy,
uh,
that is something like 3000 years old.
And this particular mummy was a,
was a woman who had a toe that was
amputated for some reason and the toe was
replaced by a synthetic.
Um,
we're not a synthetic and natural
material fashion to look like a toe.
This is made of a wood.
And so just to acknowledge that people
have probably tried to use the materials
that were in the world around
them, uh, to replace, uh,
parts of the body that were lost to
trauma or disease for thousands of years.
And, uh, we've gotten quite
good at it in some senses,
but there is still significant
problems left to solve.
And the other side of the slide here,
I wanted to show you what I think
is a remarkable, uh, material.
So this clear part here is a lens
that's actually implanted into the eye.
So it's like a contact lens,
but it's permanently placed in side
the eye over your natural lens.
And this is for people
that have very severe, uh,
difficulty envisioned because,
uh,
the properties of their
natural lens have changed.
And so you can put an artificial
materials, it's made of a polymer,
a inside the eye, and uh, it can stay
there for the rest of their lives,
restoring their vision to near normal
and requiring no other effort on their
part.
They don't have to put in the contact
lens every day because it's there inside
there eye all the time. So, uh,
so what kinds of materials are these
that we can use now to replace or restore
the function of, of, um,
of tissues that, that are,
that are damaged?
Well,
many of the materials that are used most
commonly in with the most success now
are polymers or plastics. And, uh, we,
we've talked about some
different aspects of,
of polymers in medicine
throughout the course here.
What I wanted to show you
on this slide is, and again,
not that you would memorize or even
be able to read all the details here,
but there are a large number of different
synthetic materials that now are
produced and regularly used
in medical applications.
And polymers, as you
know, are, um, it's a,
uh, our manufactured products. They're,
most of them are, are, um, are, um,
made from, uh, products that are
derived from petroleum or oil.
They're organic molecules,
typically small units that are
polymerized together to form long chains.
And because the individual molecules
in a polymer are long chains,
when you put a bunch of
them together in a material,
they entangled together and they give
you a nice material properties so you're
not falling down to the ground now
because the plastic chairs that you're
sitting on are quite strong. And, uh,
this polymer material that makes up the
base of the chairs is able to support
your weight and, uh, and does it, uh,
very reliably for a long period of
time. Um, you also notice that uh, the,
these chairs, if they were made
out of wood, they'd be very heavy.
But these are quite light, right?
You can pick them up easily.
If they're made out of metal,
they would be much heavier. Uh,
they might be stronger but they would be,
but they would be much heavier.
And so one of the advantages of polymer
materials is that you can make things
that have quite a lot of strength
but are still fairly light, right?
That's one of the advantages of,
of polymer materials.
You can also change properties of the
polymers and that's one of the things that
engineers have learned how to do a with
quite a large degree of sophistication
over the last a hundred years or so.
So you can make many different kinds
of polymers now that dipper in the
chemistry of the monomers that are linked
together to make these long chains.
You can of course change
the length of the chain.
So you can make materials that are
made up of polymers that have very long
chains, are shorter chains.
And as you could imagine,
that changes properties like the material
property of elasticity that we talked
about a few weeks ago.
And we've discovered mainly through
a process of trial and error,
but that many of these materials
are biocompatible. That is,
you can put them in contact with
tissues of the body and the,
the side effects of implanting that
material or not severe. Now in a few, uh,
in a few slides I'm going to tell you
more about how the body responds to bio
materials.
And what you'll see is that the response
can be very mild to some materials that
are inert. It can be, uh, quite vigorous
to materials that aren't so a nerd.
And so one needs to select a material
that's appropriate for the application
that you want to use it for,
has the right properties for
the application and also has,
has the right extent of compatibility
in the tissue you want to use it in.
But this is just to show you kind of the
range of materials that can be used now
in some of the applications,
uh, in which they're used.
And we'll talk about that as we go
through the lecture today. Well,
one of the applications I've already
talked about last week was making,
uh,
tubes of polymers,
tubes of polymers that can be used to
replace the conduits through which blood
flow.
And this slide shows you some
examples of arterial graphs.
So synthetic materials that
are used to replace a segment,
let's say of the aorta.
And this might be needed because the
patient has had some kind of trauma where
their aorta has become ruptured, like
in a car accident for example. Uh,
it's a deep within your body.
So it has to,
we'd have to be a pretty significant
trauma in order to hurt your aorta.
But more commonly,
sometimes there are diseases of the
or a order where the wall of the order
becomes weak and um,
and uh,
causes what's called an aneurysm
or a weak spot in the, uh,
in the artery that can balloon out.
And obviously if that becomes so weak that
it bursts, that's a medical emergency.
So if you diagnose those early and up,
then you can replace that segment of
the aorta with a synthetic polymer.
And this has been done for decades.
Now.
There are several different materials
that can be used in this way.
And because the aorta is a,
is a large caliber vessel,
it stays patent.
That is,
the blood can flow through
continuously for many decades. And uh,
this is true for vessels that are larger
than say five millimeters in diameter.
But as the size goes down,
it becomes more difficult to use
synthetic materials in these applications.
So you can't use a synthetic material
like this in the coronary arteries,
for example,
of the heart.
And we talked about that several weeks
ago and I'll show you some pictures that
show you why that wouldn't work in
smaller diameter vessels in a few moments.
Well, most of the materials that are used
here were initially developed for other
purposes. The two most common
materials that are used in, in,
in conduits like this are Dacron,
which is a synthetic polymer
that was, uh, first, uh,
it's used for lots of things,
but it's made into clothing for example.
And a surgeon's like it because it's,
uh,
because it has properties,
you can sell it easily, right?
So you imagine that a material that's
going to be used in an application like
this, a surgeon has to be able to
sow into it, uh, fairly readily.
It has to be able to hold a suture and
that suture line has to make a neat
connection or a nasty Moses
with the native vessel.
And so surgeons being able to,
so in the mud into the material reliably
is obviously an important part of the
design and Dacron a tech style
has a nice property that way.
The other material that's used often is
a material you are familiar with called
Goretex and Gortex is basically Teflon.
It's Teflon that is treated in a
special way so that it becomes porous.
And you know, one of the properties
of Teflon, you use it as,
as cookware for example, because
things don't stick to it, right?
It's not as sticky polymer.
It's barely a nerd too,
particularly proteins that
might stick on the surface, uh,
but on its own it would not be porous
and so it wouldn't allow any molecules to
pass through.
Gortex on the other hand is fashioned
and his is a picture of Gortex at very
high magnification here.
So it has small pores in it,
pours that are so small that a droplet
of water can't pass through but molecules
of water can, right? That's
why Gortex is so useful as a,
as a material for uh,
for hiking for rain gear.
It allows water to evaporate through it
but doesn't allow drops of water to go
in.
So you can make a waterproof material
that still allows your body to sweat and
for vapers to come off your body.
But that's an allow water to go in
that same property makes it useful for
arterial graphs as well.
And there's some facts on this slide that
show you how many of these operations
that use these kinds of materials
are performed every year.
Another example of using a synthetic
materials like that is in the heart valve.
We talked about how heart valves
function several weeks ago.
We talked about how your heart becomes
very inefficient and it's pumping action
if the valves don't work properly.
And uh,
there are diseases of valves
that are not uncommon.
And so many people decades
ago died because it, you know,
relatively young ages because
their heart valves would start,
stop working and their heart,
even though it was beating properly,
could not deliver the flow rate
that was needed to sustain life.
So here's an early example
of a mechanical valve,
a totally synthetic material that
could be used to replace a heart valve.
Now this is a collar here,
which is made of a tech stall
that can be sewn in to the spot,
to the ring of tissue
where the heart valve goes.
So you can see that white material there,
there's a metal ring underneath
it and on both sides of this ring,
there's a cage,
a small cage on the bottom,
and a larger cage on the top right.
So the heart would be down here,
the ventricle would be
down below this here.
And so if there was pressure on this
side, it would force the ball up, right?
So when the pressure in the left
ventricle got to be higher than the aorta,
it would force the ball up and
then flow would go out, right?
Cause the ball sitting in this
position completely seals the opening.
But when the pressure
pushes the ball up than it,
than it opens up a pathway around it.
So blood can come out through
the sides and the ball goes up,
but it doesn't go away, right? Because
it's constrained by this cage on the top.
Now when the pressure here gets
higher than the pressure down here,
the ball falls back down and it reseals
so it does exactly what we wanted or
what we described a heart valve is doing.
That is opening up when the
pressure difference was right,
when the pressure was higher
in the ventricle and the aorta,
and then closing again when the pressure
in the aorta was higher than the
ventricle. Now the problem with this is
you remember how the normal valve opens?
It opens like, like a doorway, right?
The normal valve opens like a doorway
and so the, the part that's shut
totally opens and so there's a very clear
path for flow in this kind of a ball
valve.
The ball is still in the way.
And so the fluid has to go around the
ball in order to inject into the aorta.
For example, if this was an
aortic valve, uh, the, the, the,
and because it has to go around it,
if there's an obstacle to blood flow
creates an additional resistance.
So your,
your heart has to work harder in order
to overcome the resistance of the flow
going around this large ball that's in
the center. So it works well as a valve,
but it's not a very efficient valve and
that it requires your heart to work, uh,
to work more to get a certain flow
rate because it's blocking this ball is
blocking the center of the flow.
In addition,
you can imagine this ball slamming
up and then slamming back down,
up and down could cause mechanical
damage to the blood. And it does.
And blood consists not just
of water and molecules,
but sells like red blood cells.
And these cells are sensitive
to mechanical forces.
And so every time this
valve opens and closes,
it breaks a certain number of
blood cells. Right. And that's,
that's also something that you can
live with but isn't perfect, right?
The most, uh, a better
design was made. Um, in,
I think about the 1970s,
it's this valve that's shown
here in many ways it's similar.
It has the same kind of a tech
still ring and metal on the outside.
So now it's shown sort of sort of end on,
so you're looking through the valve
and what you don't see here are two,
what are called leaflets. These are
made of metal and they fold like this,
so close like this. And then
they open like that, right?
And so it's more like a swinging door
and also responds to pressure because it
can only open one way. It goes
like this, it won't go like that.
So it only opens in one direction in
response to a pressure drop. And then it,
and the other way.
And so this is now the most commonly used
design for a totally synthetic valve,
but still a popular valve that's used
are these two valves that are shown here.
This one is from a cow.
This one is from a pig and they're
natural valves that are recovered from the
animals and then they're treated,
they're cross linked with a chemical
so that they become permanent,
uh, structures, nonliving
structures, uh, now and uh,
these sort of biosynthetic valves,
uh,
what's called in the caption here.
A bioprosthesis prosthesis
just means replacement, right?
So this is derived from natural tissue
is an alternative to this mechanical
valve. And Physicians, we'll, uh,
we'll use one of these types of valves
or another depending on which of your
valves needs replacement,
what their own experiences with people
that have diseases like the ones they're
treating. And, but there are
these several options available.
So,
uh,
one of the problems when he put any
synthetic material or any material other
than your own tissues in contact with
blood is that you will start a process
called coagulation or blood clotting.
And of course,
this natural reaction is important to,
um, to our lives, right? If you,
if you damage a blood vessel,
the blood vessel becomes ruptured.
All of a sudden the blood is exposed to a
surface. It's not used to seeing, right?
You damage the blood vessel and instead
of the blood flowing through a nice tube
that has a very consistent
endothelial cell lining,
it's now exposed to the tissue outside,
right when the blood vessel gets ruptured
and when it's exposed to the tissue
outside,
a series of chemical reactions gets
initiated and that series of chemical
reactions is called the
coagulation cascade.
And it involves proteins that are also
enzymes that go from an inactive state to
an active state. And this is
described in the book in some detail.
I'm not going to ask you questions
about the molecular details of this.
I want you to do to sort of
understand the concept that um,
that a protein in the blood gets activated
by exposure to a foreign surface and
it creates an activated enzyme,
which then activates another enzyme,
which activates another enzyme on,
through this network.
And the final result is that a molecule
in your blood called fibrinogen gets
converted into a cross
linked network called fibrin.
Okay?
So exposure to a foreign surface sets
off a series of chemical reactions.
The end result is that a natural protein
in your blood that's normally dissolved
and just flowing around in your blood
called fibrinogen gets cross linked into a
gel or a semi solid material,
and this is the formation of a clot.
Now when this reaction happens,
this cross linking of fibrinogen into
fibrin happens there usually cells that
are trapped there as well because these
crosslinking reactions occur in blood
and there's lots of blood that gets
cross linked into this network,
but you form a semi solid structural
material that seals off the area of the
blood vessel that's damaged,
right?
And so blood now stays within your
circulatory system, the bleeding stops,
and that that seal that gets made is
a chemically cross linked version of
fiboronectin. And you know it as
a blood clot, you cut yourself,
you see a clot later, it looks red
because it looks red, but it's solid.
It looks red because there's
blood cells trapped in it,
red blood cells trapped in it.
It's solid because the basis of it is
this cross linked network of proteins.
So this happens if you expose blood,
anytime you explodes exposed blood
to a foreign material, it happens.
If you put a heart valve,
an artificial heart valve
in the blood pathway,
this clotting reaction
will start to happen.
And that's what's shown in this slide
here. You can't see it too well,
but this surface would
ordinarily look smooth.
It doesn't look smooth because there
are proteins coagulate it on the surface
here.
These proteins have fibrin Nekton that
are being converted into a fibrin jail.
And there are also specialized
cells that also find these, uh,
these fiber networks and they
spread out to help form a barrier.
These cells are called platelets.
And you know,
platelets are also important
in blood clotting reactions.
So one of the problems with
every synthetic material
that's used to replace a
component of your circulatory system,
like a heart valve,
is that you form a thin layer of clot
on the surface of blood clot on the
surface.
Now what you hope is that that happens
within the first few hours of when the
heart valve is replaced
and then it doesn't happen
anymore because it becomes a
sort of natural biological surface now
and your body tolerates it all right.
So,
um,
but it required only this only happens
with certain kinds of materials.
And so that's one of the criteria for
selecting materials that are used as heart
valves is that they have to
be able to support sort of a,
a mild clotting reaction, right? A mile,
not a severe clotting reaction because
what happens if this clot keeps forming
on the surface,
the,
the clot gets thicker and thicker on
the surface and eventually since there's
blood flowing by pieces of that
clot could be expelled from or,
or, or, or detached from the surface of
the material and they would flow into your
blood. And if they float up
into your brain, for example,
they could clog smart,
smaller arteries inside your brain
and cut off blood flow to that region,
right?
That process is called embolism.
Embolism is when a small
particle is released into
your bloodstream and embolism
can cause all sorts of unwanted effects,
right?
So a bad heart valve might
give you a stroke in the brain.
Um, this is one kind of
reaction to a biomaterial.
These other two pictures show
you other kinds of reactions.
Here's a material labelled as m here
that's implanted under the skin.
And what you see is that after time,
this unusual layer of tissue forms,
this is called a part of
the foreign body reaction.
Your body tries to form us kind of scar
around the material and I'll show you
how that happens in a cartoon. And it just
a minute. And materials that are very,
uh, that are not so in
Nerd, uh, can cause, uh,
extensive cellular reactions like the
one I show on the bottom here, these,
these dots here are cells
from your inflammatory system,
their neutrophils and macrophages that
are collecting at the site of the foreign
material.
The material here was a mash and you can
see where the fibers of the Mesh are,
where there's clear dots here,
but you can see there's lots
of cells that are recruited.
If you showed this to an
experienced pathologist,
he would say these cells are coming in
as part of the inflammatory response as
part of the unwanted
response to this material.
Every material produces a
different reaction when you
put it in the to the body
and the details of the reaction depend
on the chemistry of the material.
It's mechanical properties,
how its surface is treated if
the surface is rough or smooth,
and so from an engineering perspective,
those are all things that
we can potentially change.
So we can design materials hopefully
that minimize the response of the body to
it.
But in general you can't make the response
go away and the response appears to
have some general characteristics.
There's general ways that
your body responds to all
materials and those general
ways are shown in this cartoon and
that the in the first few minutes,
seconds or up to an hour,
when you put the material into the body,
it becomes coated with proteins. Now,
where do these proteins come from?
If this was a material that we
use in the in contact with blood,
those proteins probably came from
the blood. If this was a heart valve,
for example, then these proteins
probably came from the blood.
If you looked at the proteins,
they breed primarily the abundant proteins
that are naturally abundant in blood
like albumin, fibrinogen, other
kinds of proteins like that.
But protein absorption
happens very quickly.
Within the next few days,
cells will start to accumulate around
the material and it appears that what we
know now suggests that these cells are
recruited to the material because of the
proteins that are absorbed and you can
understand that you know that proteins
are surround all the cells in our body.
We talked about extra cellular matrix
and how there are concentrated gels of
proteins that surround almost every cell.
So sales like to stick to protein layers.
And if you have a material that's coated
with a protein, cells will stick to it.
Now the first cells that arrive and
that stick ourselves of the inflammatory
response and the inflammatory response
is the natural process of your body
responding to some potentially harmful,
uh,
event.
And these cells are moving
around in your body all the time.
They flow through your bloodstream,
they crawl through your tissues,
they're looking for something
potentially bad to happen.
And then when it does,
they tried to start the healing process.
And so these cells recognize that proteins
are attached to the material and they
begin to accumulate at this site here,
the first cells that
arrive are neutrophils. The
second set are macrophages.
Now those are the cells that I show
accumulating and high concentration around
this material here. And what they do
is they start the healing process.
And they do that in a variety of ways.
One is that they release enzymes that
tried to digest whatever is around and
they also send out signals to recruit
other kinds of cells to come in.
And that's what's shown in this second
stage here is that the cells condense
into a layer.
They form what are called giant cells,
which are basically macrophages that
fuse together to form a giant cell,
which in some circumstances can can
completely encapsulate this material and
they send out signals to the
rest of your body that say,
something's going on here.
We need your help in healing.
Whatever is happening at this local site.
If,
if this was a splinter for example,
that you've got underneath your skin,
your body's response to it would be to
form a scar all the way around it and to
try to digest it,
right,
and if you've ever had to splinter
that you couldn't get out,
you might have waited for a few days
or a few weeks and eventually the
splintered gets covered with some kind
of a tissue and it comes up towards the
top of your skin and eventually
gets ejected from your body. Right?
That's one kind of a healing response.
That's natural.
If that splinter was too deep,
it would just get totally covered
with a scar scar all around it.
And this cells that are in the scar
tissue would be secreting enzymes and
digestive chemicals inside
trying to the splinter.
And if it was made of wood,
eventually it would dissolve and it
would completely disappear, right?
If it's made of a synthetic polymer that
doesn't respond or doesn't get digested
by those chemicals,
what happens is that a stable scar
forms around this material that never
disappears.
Okay.
And but the material is isolated
now from the rest of your body.
Now I mentioned that different materials
produce different levels of response
like this and some of the responses are
very mild in that you get very little
protein absorbed. You get very
few sales recruited to the site,
you'd get not a scar,
but maybe a thin layer of or tissue
that would form around the outside,
right?
So some responses are mild and those are
considered biocompatible and some are
more vigorous and those are
considered to be not so compatible,
right?
But it happens with almost
every material we know.
Let's talk for a few minutes about a
completely different kind of application.
And again,
this is one that I mentioned a few
weeks ago when we were talking about bio
mechanics. Um, and that
is replacement of the hip.
And so I just show you this, uh, this
drawing here to remind you of hip anatomy.
So the pelvic bones here,
which form a girdle at the
level of your waist and uh,
and there's a cup inside the pelvic
girdle called the Acetabulum.
And into that cup,
the head of the Femur fits in a ball and
socket joints so that your hip has all
the range of movement that we talked
about in class and in section a few weeks
ago. If there's a disease of this
bone and this needs to be replaced,
then the general procedure now is to
replace not only the part this, this, uh,
part of the hip that contains the,
the joint,
the ball, uh, but also to
replace the socket as well.
So you create a total hip replacement
where you've got a material that you put
into the socket and a material that
you put onto the femur to fit into that
socket.
Yeah,
I showed you this picture before
and this was a, this is a,
a design of a material like this.
You see a metal cup
that serves as the new acetabulum.
You see a metal ball that is attached to
the femur and this ball fits into this
socket.
Now if you just had metal on metal and
you tried to move that metal ball inside
that socket, that doesn't, that
doesn't work so well, metal on metal,
there's some friction between these two.
If this was a motor and
you had metal on metal,
you put oil in between there to
lubricate, right? But this is not
possible in this situation.
So you put something else in there to
lubricate and the something else is this
white material.
It's a layer of polymer,
a thin of polymer that also forms a cup,
fits exactly into this acetabulum piece,
and the ball of the femur then is
gliding on this smooth polymer piece,
right?
Um,
these polymer pieces have been made of
a variety of different materials, um,
over the years,
a Teflon and now most of the pieces now
are made of high density polyethylene.
Bobby,
yeah.
Sorry. Not here, not hearing you.
Okay.
Modern hip replacements.
And I'll show you some,
some new designs now typically have
a lifetime of closer to 20 years.
Uh,
but um,
I'll tell you why many of them have
to be replaced after about 10 years.
The older design ones. So, um,
design has gotten better
over time with these.
And I'll talk about some of the
ways that it's gotten better. Well,
one of the problems is
that this piece here,
this ball of the theme or this
part is going to replace the hip,
has to be very firmly attached
to the rest of your, uh, to the,
to the rest of the bones
of your leg to your femur.
Because if you're standing on one leg,
all the weight of your body is really, uh,
is really being carried by
this piece of material here.
So that's why they're made out of metal.
Because metals are strong and relatively
light and you need a strong material.
Plastic wouldn't work in this setting,
right?
Plastic wouldn't work in this setting
because plastic is too elastic.
Um, at most plastics are two
elastic, whereas metal is,
uh, is a stiffer and can
hold your weight. Uh,
what you didn't see in that previous
picture is that there's a long piece here
that goes down into the bone and this
long piece that goes into the bone allows
you to fix the ball of the
femur to the rest of the femur.
And it's fixed because this P,
this metal part down here goes down
into the shaft of your femur and then is
held there.
So it's kind of like a long thick nail
that goes down into the length of the
bone.
And what you hope is that
that large surface area in
contact metal to bone holds
the whole piece into place so
that the hip operates smoothly.
Now.
Um,
now one of the goals of this is
would be decrypted design that, uh,
that naturally integrates into your
bone and what's called on this, uh,
self locking mechanism. So what would
his self locking mechanism be like? Well,
maybe you put holes in this material,
like the whole shown here so that
your bone could grow through it.
Okay.
As your bone heals around this implant,
what if bone could grow
through the material? Then
you'd have bone on both sides,
sort of locking it in. That would
be the perfect design, right?
That would be a, let's say not
perfect. That would be a good design.
The problem is that's going
to take some time, right?
That's going to take some time.
And so you want the person to be able
to stand up and walk and move around and
function in the period
before that happens.
And so what is usually done is that a
nother material is used to lock these
materials temporarily in place.
And that material is called bone cement.
It's a, it's a polymer that can be
polymerized when you shine light on it.
And it's not too dissimilar from the
materials that dentists use now to fill
cavities, right? If you
had a cavity filled,
and recently they put some
sort of a material into your,
into the cavity, and then they
shine a light on it, right?
They put on the goggles and they cover up
your face and they shine a light on it.
And the polymer that they put into the
cavity polymerizes and forms a hard
surface here, they put the polymer
all around the Acetabular Cup.
They put the polymer into the recess that
they push the bone into and then they
shine light on it so that it starts to,
um,
so that it polymerizes and hardened and
forms a very tough material that fixes
this thing in place.
That's called bone cement and the,
and the material is
polymethyl methacrylate.
Okay,
so you can see that this,
this now involves at least three
different kinds of materials, right?
There's the metal that's
used to make the implant.
There's the polymer lining that's used
to lubricate the joint between the two
metals and there's the other
kind of polymer, the Samantha,
it's used to fix this in place, uh, in
the, in contact with your natural bone.
Here's an implant that was removed from
a patient after, as Bobby mentioned,
after maybe 10 years,
they found out that their hip wasn't
working so well anymore and they were
starting to get pain from their hip
joint or they weren't able to move it
through the whole range of motion that
they'd been able to move it through in
years past.
And in this particular case,
this joint was removed.
Here's the, here's the ball,
here's the Acetabular Cup where
there's no polymer anymore.
Where did the polymer go?
Um,
one of the problems with older
designs of these materials,
particularly when they use
Teflon and not polyethylene,
is that over time as you used your hip,
while there wasn't much friction between
the metal ball and the polyethylene or
the Teflon Cup,
there was enough friction where the
Teflon would start to where it would start
to wear down and then we'd get thinner
and thinner over time and eventually,
as in this case with this particular
patient could totally disappear if it
disappeared,
then you've got metal on metal now harder
to move your hip probably causing pain
when you move it as well because the
pieces aren't lubricated as well.
In addition, what happens is that when
this metal is moving against the polymer,
it wears down,
but the polymer doesn't vanish.
It has to go somewhere, right? And what,
what most people think is happening is
that tiny particles of the Teflon or the
polyethylene are being created
locally, right? As where happens,
you're wearing down the material,
you're creating many small particles
of the material that are released,
and those particles then can
start an inflammatory response.
Your body will start to respond
to these small particles. And um,
and that can also cause
local inflammation,
can cause reactions of tissue,
which also lead to pain. All right,
so this is one of the biggest
problems in design of a, of hips.
One of the reasons they've gotten better
is that people have gotten better about
making materials that resist this kind
of where and that's why they last for 20
years now instead of 10 years
as they did in the past. Um,
and there are newer kinds of materials
that people are beginning to create and
they're new in a variety of ways.
One of the ways they're new is that they
don't require as much bone cement any
longer. So this Acetabular Cup,
for example, is made of a ceramic,
which is very porous and which sticks
to bone more naturally and more easily
than the old metal cups used to.
Another difference in this design is
instead of having a metal head which moves
against the uh, metal ball, which
moves against the polymer socket,
this one has a ceramic head and the
friction between ceramic and a polymer is
even less than the friction between
a, a, a metal and a polymer.
These are also much lighter.
Ceramics are lighter,
they're very strong and you can
create a joint that lasts even, uh,
even longer with materials
like this. So, um,
so continue engineer's are continuously
making improvements in the materials
that go into joints like this and they're
making improvements in the design to
make them easier for surgeons to implant.
And now a total hip replacement,
putting these pieces into a patient
takes only about an hour in the operating
room,
which is remarkable given the amount
that has to happen during that time.
I want to quickly review
some other kinds of, uh,
of artificial materials and I'm going to
talk for just a minute about something
we talked about before. Uh,
dialysis for kidney failure.
It's an example of what's called
an extra corporeal blood treatment.
Meaning that blood extra means outside,
corporeal means body,
extra corporeal is outside the body.
You take the blood outside of the patient,
you pass it through a device,
the treatment device, and then it goes
back into the patient. And so you know,
you saw in a section what
a dialyzer unit looks like,
but it's an example of a treatment where
blood is passed through some kind of a
device. Something happens to the
blood, something good happens,
and then the blood is
returned to the patient. Um,
a dialyzer might look like this.
There's blood that comes into a chamber
and that blood throught flows through
many, many different hollow fibers.
So blood flowing through these fibers.
On the outside of the fibers,
you're flowing a second
solution called the dialysate.
And so molecules waste
molecules like urea,
which are inside the blood capillaries
diffuse out into the dialysate.
They're removed from the blood.
So blood with a high concentration
of urea comes in this side,
blood with lower Uriah comes out this
side and goes back to the patient.
And that urea is removed by the dialysate
that goes around the hollow fibers.
Well,
what if you change this design slightly
and ask it to do something different and
instead of just flowing in a solution of
céline or a balanced salt solution that
was designed to pull your
REIA out of the blood,
what if you put cells in the
area around these hollow fibers?
What if you put cells in and what if
they were cells from the pancreas for
example,
so now blood is flowing through this
hollow fiber just like before and on the
outside there's not just
a solution of of salt,
but there are cells from the pancreas.
And what if this membrane work
the same way it doesn't dialysis,
it allowed small molecular
weight molecules to go through.
Then if blood came in
and it had sugar in it,
that sugar would diffuse out into the,
into the fluid in the shell.
What we used to call the dialysate.
If blood sugar is high and these
are sales from the pancreas,
what do cells of the pancreas do when
they see high concentrations of blood
sugar?
They secrete insulin and that insulin
would be secreted and it would flow back
through the tube into the blood.
You could make potentially an artificial
pancreas this way that was used to
treat blood outside the body.
So a,
so a diabetic patient, blood comes
out, it goes through this device.
Glucose would stimulate the
cells to secrete insulin.
The insulin would go back into the blood
and the insulin would be returned to
the body. And if these
pancreas cells worked properly,
they would respond just like a normal
pancreas does. When sugar goes up,
insulin goes up, sugar goes
down, insulin goes down,
and it does that automatically because
the cells are responding to the glucose.
That would be very inconvenient.
It might be a good solution,
but it would be inconvenient
if you're a diet, had diabetes,
and you needed this all the time to be
taking the blood out of the body and you
have this device that you have
to carry around with you, right?
So what if you made it so
you could implant it totally
inside the body as well?
And that's what this show,
that's what's this diagram shows here.
Here's an example of that
dialysis, uh, unit, uh,
that is the dialysis like
unit, but it's made, uh,
to be very small.
You can see the shell.
The outside shell here is a clear
plastic, um, it's about the size of, uh,
of um, uh, smaller than a hockey puck,
but not a lot smaller than a hockey puck.
And there's a tube that comes
in that brings blood in,
there's a tube that comes out and brings
blood out and this tube goes in and
then it wraps around several times
inside and then it goes back out.
And that wrapped that, those, those, uh,
those coils of tubing that wrap around
inside are all surrounded by sales from
the pancreas.
If you hook this up inside the body such
that you have blood going in one side
and then coming out the other,
then you've created a device
that potentially could
treat diabetes automatically
and continuously as long as the
cells were alive inside this shell.
So this was in a design of a, what's
called a bio hybrid, uh, pancreas.
It's made of synthetic materials,
the kind of materials we've
been talking about polymers.
And it's filled with live cells that are
harvested from a pancreas now because,
because there's a material that
separates the cells from your body,
unlike in tissue engineering where we
wanted the cells to integrate into the
body.
Now there's a material that separates
the cells so I don't have to use cells
that are immunologically matched with
the patient right there separated.
I think I don't even
have to use human cells.
I could use cells from another animal as
long as they respond to shoot to sugar
and make insulin that
works in the patient.
And so you might be able to use cells
from a pig and create an artificial
pancreas that works in a person.
Now,
these designs were made almost 20 years
ago now and they work fairly well.
Uh, there are, there are several
problems that still have not been solved.
One is that the cells don't live forever.
We know from cell culture,
the problem with maintaining cells
outside the body and here you would like
cells that lasts for a very long period
of time and continue to secrete insulin.
Um,
so they don't last for,
for a long enough for this to be
an effective therapy in people yet
a device that is similar to that,
uh,
the same kind of idea is used to treat
patients that have severe liver disease.
Now you might be think about an
implantable device like that,
but unlike the, uh, the pancreas,
a device that replaced the
functions of your liver,
we talked about all the
different functions of your
liver to make an artificial
device like that pancreas that provided
all the functions of your liver would
need a lot of liver cells and
it would have to be pretty big.
So people aren't yet thinking about
an implantable device for liver.
What they do use it though is for as
a device to support the function of
patients. If this is a patient
who has a disease liver,
they're waiting for a liver transplant,
how can you keep them alive without a
functioning liver during the time when
they're waiting for a
transplant to arrive?
What some hospitals are now using our
devices in which pig liver cells are
suspended in a hollow fiber reactor,
very much like a dialysis unit.
And so the patient is on
something like dialysis,
but dialysis that not only
removes waste products, dialysis,
that provides liver function as well,
because inside this unit,
our liver cells are hepatocytes that are
performing all the functions that liver
inside your body would perform,
right?
So this is another example
of an artificial organ and
artificial organ that's
used, uh, in, in, um, uh,
many thousands of times
around the country.
Every day is this unit here called a heart
lung bypass or cardiopulmonary bypass
machine.
And this machine can replace the function
of your lungs and your heart during an
operation. So if a surgeons
need to operate on your heart,
they can hook you up to this machine.
Instead, they can stop your heart,
your own heart. And, uh,
then this machine will take over the
functions of both your hearts and your,
and your lungs. How does it do that?
It does that because there's a pump,
a mechanical pump,
there's blood being removed from the body.
And uh, from the venous side,
this is blood that needs oxygen.
It's being pumped at the normal cardiac
output through a device that oxygenates
it. So the pumps replace
the function of your heart.
The oxygenator replaces
the function of your lungs.
Blood is pumped through the oxygenator.
It goes from being oxygen,
poor carbon dioxide,
rich to being carbon dioxide,
poor oxygen rich and then
goes back into your body.
You can remain on a pump like
this for several hours while,
uh, while the surgeon, uh,
does a heart transplant,
replaces your heart while the while
the surgeon does a valve replacement,
while the surgeon replaces a
coronary artery, for example,
this machine can keep your,
can basically serve as an artificial
heart and lungs during surgery.
Of course,
one of the things that you would like to
do is be able to do something like this,
but to totally replace the function of
the heart and have this is only valuable
when you're in the operating
room. It requires a, an extensive,
um, um, uh,
an extensive and talented team
to operate it, to keep you alive.
What would,
what has been a goal of biomedical
engineers for many decades is to design an
artificial heart that could be totally
implanted and could replace the function
of your heart when your heart begins
to fail. And we're not there yet.
There are still, there are
still problems. And what this,
what this slide shows you is some of
the divine designs that have been tested
over time. This is an early design,
not have an artificial heart, but of a,
of a, of a, uh,
artificial ventricular assist device.
This is a device that's supposed to
give your ventricle and extra boost, uh,
when it needs it.
If your heart is failing and your normal
cardiac muscle isn't able to create the
force to get, uh, your blood
pressure and flow up high enough. Uh,
you can read more about
this in the book. This, uh,
these two are cartoons that show you
what was called the Jarvik heart,
the Jarvik seven heart,
which was implanted in a number of
patients and still used in some clinical
centers around the world.
When a patient own heart has failed and
they're waiting for a heart transplant,
the surgeons will sometimes
make the decision,
the patient is not going to live without
some kind of support for their heart
function.
So they'll put an artificial heart in
just to keep them alive during the period
when they're hopefully waiting
for a heart to come. Uh,
and this is the most recent of
those. This is the albacore, uh,
heart.
Uh,
this is made of the same kinds of
materials we've been talking about made of
polymers, a very smooth, reliable, uh,
pump in a very small form that
can be hooked up, uh, to uh,
your normal vasculature and take
over the function of the heart.
So many of the problems that have been
largely solved up to this point here is
to develop materials that could be in
continuous contact with blood and not have
the kinds of clotting or other
reactions that could, uh,
that could cause problems if you use
this kind of a device and a person,
those problems have not entirely,
but largely been solved.
The major problem with an artificial
heart now is how to power it.
That producing all this mechanical energy
that's required to pump blood and keep
your blood pressure high requires energy.
And so all of these hearts
have an external power source
with them. So there are,
there are cables that come from
inside the patient outside to a,
to a system of batteries
that power the heart.
And it's not possible yet to make that
power source small enough that it could
be,
uh,
conveniently either implanted or
worn by the patient for chronic use.
And that's one of the biggest problems
with the design of this particular
artificial organ now.
Okay.
So we'll meet this afternoon
in section a course review and,
uh, please come with questions.
I, as I mentioned, I'll
have some material prepared,
uh, to just describe what's covered that
we've covered in the last half of the
course on the final
spin. A pleasure. Thanks.